and walker furniture making another home  for the holidays delivery today this  time to a grandmother on the east side  of town her name is angela powell and  she was nominated for the giveaway after  she took guardianship of three of her 19  grandchildren to remove them from an  abusive situation so powell relocated  from chicago she had nothing  all of them were sleeping on the floor  well today that all changed  furniture  is is what we do and  and it's the best way to  give back to the community this is the  28th year that we've been doing this  it's just so much joy to  be able to be in a situation where you  can help others and others that are in  need  by the way a pal and her grandkids as  you can see there also got a christmas  tree poinsettias special delivery of  christmas presents and food walker  furniture's home for the holidays  deliveries will continue all through the  holiday  they plan to surprise a total of 35  families oh she's got tears of joy there  all smiling